foreign
[Music]
your Weekly News show FYI is back in
Downing Street
[Music]
less than a week after Liz dress
resigned Rishi sunak became leader of
the conservative party
but why have we had so many prime
ministers recently
I will unite our country
not with words
but with action
and we have an exclusive report from
Africa where more than 20 million people
face starvation because of covid
conflict and climate change
[Music]
hi there Hi and hi Scarlett in Downing
Street hi so another quiet week in
Downing Street then yeah right look how
many reporters are here from all over
the world I mean who said politics was
boring yeah I mean we've had five
conservative party prime ministers in
the last six years and three of them in
the last four months it's crazy in it so
Scarlett how come we've had so many
prime ministers in the last few years
that famous door behind me has been a
bit of a revolving door
so back in 2016 David Cameron felt you
should quit because his campaign for the
UK to remain in the European Union
failed
Theresa May took over but then she
resigned in 2019 because she couldn't
get politicians to agree on how we
actually leave the European Union
Boris Johnson took her place but this
year he resigned because he broke the
very rules he introduced on public
Gatherings during the covid pandemic
let's try Square after just 45 days
because her ideas on how to help us with
the rising cost of everyday essentials
actually made some things even more
expensive and her party lost trust in
her
Boris Johnson dashed back from a holiday
hoping to get a second chance at being
prime minister but then changed his mind
it was Rishi sunak who got the support
of his party he is Britain's first Hindu
prime minister and a very successful
businessman he knows his money too he
used to be the chancellor
the politician who decides how the
government spends its money
but is it right for prime ministers to
come and go at a time where big
decisions need to be made on big issues
so we found out that Prime Ministers are
supposed to stay in power for five years
and then there has to be a general
election where the public gets the
chance to vote again on who should run
the country
now it's important to point out that
Boris Johnson and his political party
did win a general election back in 2019
so here's the really important info
adults don't actually vote for a prime
minister they vote for a local MP A
Member of Parliament from a particular
party the MP with the most votes gets a
seat here in Parliament it's where
politicians debate and vote on the
things the government wants to do
usually the party with the most MPS
becomes the government and the party
leader becomes prime minister but if
their party is not happy with them they
can force them to resign and vote for a
replacement
but that's happened a lot while the
conservative party have been in charge
some politicians have been saying that
the party's been struggling and it's
time for the public to get a say on who
runs our country
did you know a government can announce a
general election at any time during
their five years in power I got a chance
to speak to two MPS from the two biggest
political parties in the UK Maggie
Throop conservative MP for ear wash and
Bridget Phillipson labor MP for Horton
and Sunderland South
is the government in serious trouble so
no the country isn't in trouble Russia
is really competent he's very good at
looking after the finance of the country
we've seen obviously three prime
ministers in three months now so there
are lots of problems and I'm not
convinced that the next prime minister
is the person to fix it well you've had
is it 5 PM's in the last six years and
four chancellors in the last four months
how can young people have faith in
politicians right now I think it's a
matter of looking at what we do locally
as well as in government what's
important at the moment is to make sure
we get stability and move on to have a
general election would actually take
even more time out which I don't think
this country can afford I think we've
seen absolute chaos now for weeks and
months but I think the British people
should have their say now obviously a
conservative MPS have had their say but
I think the British people should have a
general election and should be able to
exercise their voice one thing's for
sure the face of who runs our country
may have changed a lot in recent weeks
but the problems they need to deal with
have not changed a war in Ukraine
affecting millions of people a shortage
of fuel in everyday needs which are
leading to Rising costs for British
families
[Music]
you heard Scarlett say that there are
many people in the UK struggling
financially but it's nothing compared to
what's happening in Africa right now
yeah the three C's conflict
covid-19 and climate change have led to
millions of people struggling to find
food the conflict in Ukraine and the
pandemic means there's a shortage of
food being brought into some parts of
Africa and climate changes led to the
worst drought in 40 years destroying
livestock and crops on farms we have an
exclusive report from 12 year old Samuel
his family are farmers in Kenya in
maratha and this is his world
[Music]
my name is
I live in media Village Kenya
[Music]
this was supposed to be a farm
but there has been a long drought
and everything has died
the soil is so dry as you see that
cartoon sister in life for plants
[Music]
my community depends on healthy Harvest
to fit and provide for our people
[Music]
the rains are failed many times and now
nothing will grow you say we planted but
it was all in free
this is because there was drought and we
didn't Harvest
still we have to walk the field to
prepare for the next season even though
we don't know if it will grow what else
can we do for them the God Almighty that
we
but to give us rain so that we can plant
another
and harvest
maze is a very strong crop it needs the
least water to grow now the soil is so
dry even this will not grow
and so we have no options left
the Earth has turned to dust and our
hopes Blow Away With the Wind
[Music]
all right
lots of Charities have been trying to
get food and Medicine across Africa who
have the worst affected areas being in
the East like Kenya Somalia and Ethiopia
so we called in an expert for more info
Rose and Julio and dolo is from the
charity World Vision for helping
communities in Africa hi Rose hello will
so how is your charity helping people
like Samuel and his family my charity is
supporting families like Samuel in
providing life-saving assistance so we
have 50 million people in 45 countries
who are facing starvation and over 810
million people are going to bed very
hungry so we are taking immediate action
to save their lives and to secure their
Futures so obviously it's a serious
situation but what can we do to help
we can do a number of things so we need
to immediately save lives of these
children they are extremely thin you can
see it and they are ill and therefore
they need immediate treatment to recover
from malnutrition and the good news is
we have the tools to be able to do that
we are providing them with treatment
which comes in in the form of a packet
in of peanut paste which is high in
nutrients and helps them to recover it's
a proven cure but also in the longer
term we need to be providing support to
local Health Systems so that women girls
and children have access to nutrition
and health services but also provide
Farmers with the support they need to be
able to withstand the effects of climate
change but also reverse the impacts of
Kobe 19. I think covered a lot more of
an understanding so thank you very much
for your time and thank you for joining
us thank you thank you
one of our FYI news club members goes to
the biggest school assembly in the UK to
hear the latest on what we can do to
help tackle climate change so Maya it's
that time of year it's Halloween yeah I
love Halloween I especially love the
costumes and the decorations I like the
sweets to be honest with you well this
week I've found two spooky stories that
I've been doing the rounds online but
can you guys tell which one is fact and
which one is frighteningly fake
first up every Wizard and witch needs an
owl right but check this out apparently
this is a photo of a rare red owl with
blue eyes native to New Guinea fake or
fat
or what about this picture of a
real-life Adams Family
apparently these fright Fanatics have
the surname Adams so they dress up and
celebrate Halloween from July to October
every year creepy one of these stories
is fake but which one will reveal all
later
[Music]
1 500 pupils from around the UK crammed
into a score Hall with some pretty
famous faces from the world of
conservation to discuss climate change
one of those pupils was FYI News Club
member Halima who joins us now hi Halima
how are you I am great thanks how are
you both I'm very welcome welcome to the
show thank you so Halima your school's
FYI News Club was at the school's
climate assembly what was it all about
well it was all about empowering young
people to raise their voice and to take
action against the climate crisis there
were many inspiring talks from many
engaging and passionate speakers as well
as interactive workshops for young
people to take part in
so the three outcomes of the event were
commitment to 100 Renewable Power by
2030 and climate education for everyone
with the support and time for teachers
to to deliver this and investment in
apprenticeships jobs and training
opportunities and to tackle climate
change well it sounds like a super busy
day but it must have been amazing to be
surrounded by so many other young people
that were just as passionate as like
black is just as you yeah it was a great
atmosphere it was fantastic to see
everybody's enthusiasm
um the the speakers are really friendly
and approachable and everyone just had
so much knowledge that they were Keen to
share it was a really enjoyable
experience for me nice so there were
some pretty famous faces there in the
world of climate change who did you meet
I met Chris Packham he is a wildlife
presenter famous Wildlife presenter even
and he um he's also a conservationist he
was very friendly willing to answer all
my questions and also very patient we've
actually got a clip of that now check
this out in Greenland where the second
largest ice sheep in the world is and
the ice sheep which would contribute
most if it melts when it melts um to sea
level rise it's somewhere between 20 and
22 degrees
22 degrees I mean that's t-shirt whether
in October you know in the north of the
Arctic Circle this is this is terrifying
absolutely terrifying so the urgency for
us to exercise our voices in a polite
Democratic and peaceful way has never
been more profound you know we've got to
say to these people now is the time of
that action so he's famous which means
that a lot of people listen to him
um but do you think us kids are listened
to when we speak out about climate
change of course when you look at it
Young Voices are very powerful
incredibly powerful really if we prove
ourselves it just shows how much we can
get done and take the example of Greta
turnberg at the age of 15 she's holding
her board outside the Swedish Parliament
okay that's not gonna do much but look
in a space of four years she's done so
much she's challenged world leaders at
big events like cops 26 she's written
books and she's even organized for
ladies for future thank you so much for
your time thank you it's lovely speaking
to you lovely speaking to you both now
if you want to report on FYI then use
your setup on FY news club at your
school just like Halima did
if you have a story and want to report
an FYI or get your say on the big issues
then all you have to do is ask your
teacher to set up an FYI News Club at
your school it's pretty easy to do all
the information is on our website
you can get access to hundreds of FYI
reports and programs so you can discuss
the big issues with your mates and FYI
news club members get the chance to
report for FYI
so did you guys guess which of our
Halloween stories was fact or fake news
this photo of what was said to be a rare
red owl with blue eyes is fake it's
actually a digitally edited picture of
an owl from the Philippines
which means this picture of the
real-life Adams Family is fact Sarah
Adams and a family of five start
celebrating Halloween in July as well as
dressing up they turn their whole home
into a house of horrors for four whole
months every single year
spooky
well that's it for this week but we
thought we'd leave you with some of our
favorite pictures of Diwali the Hindu
festival of lights being celebrated
across the UK many families are also
celebrating the appointment of the
country's first Hindu prime minister
Rishi sunak bye
thank you
[Music]